savez vous que l'homme n'avait jamais
marché sur la lune et que ces images ont
été filmées en studio par stanley
kubrick himself un des plus grands
cinéastes du xxème siècle complot
[Musique]
évidemment comme strong a jamais marché
sur la lune enfin qu'est-ce qu'un
musicien de jazz et à faire dans
l'espace je veux parler du coureur
cycliste alors à neil amstrong
l'astronaute ah oui bah du coup mais je
comprends bien
dans la nuit du 20 au 21 juillet 1969
neil armstrong et buzz non pas celui-là
je parle de l'original buzz aldrin pose
le premier pied sur la lune c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire qu'une
foule autre chose que le sol terrestre
et ça si vous voulez mon avis c'est un
petit pas pour l'homme un grand pas pour
l'humanité je devrais peut-être déposé
cette phrase un moule à pic outre
l'accomplissement technologique que
cette mission représente elle aura aussi
permis de collecter 22 kg d'échantillons
rocheux provenant de la lune ça c'est
typique des géologues quand ils vont en
vacances quelque part faut toujours
qu'ils ramènent des cailloux à cette
époque nous sommes en pleine guerre
froide les états unis et l'union
soviétique joua qui peuvent faire pipi
le plus loin pour se faire peur mais à
distance par will chacun avait la bombe
atomique le moindre crêpage de chignon
aura pu causer qu'un tout petit alors
les deux grandes puissances de l'époque
ont décidé de faire la course et
notamment la course à l'espace qu'il en
sera le premier satellite artificiel
autour de la terre la russie qui mettra
le premier animal en orbite encore la
russie qui l'on verra le premier homme
dans l'espace toujours la russie 3 0 les
communistes étaient en train de mettre
la pâtée aux capitalistes qui ont un
petit peu paniqué du coup en 1962 le
président américain jfk nady a déclaré
même que nous on veut envoyer des gens
sur la lune et on fera ça avant la fin
de la décennie pas parce que ces choses
sont faciles mais parce que ces choses
sont difficiles et là les scientifiques
se sont dits halal qu'est-ce qui nous a
sorti ce jf mois maintenant on n'a plus
trop le choix de toute façon donc aller
comme en galice au boulot et c'est ainsi
que sept ans plus tard décoller nos
premiers touristes lunaire lors de la
mission apollo 11 même si wallace et
gromit l'avait fait bien avant eux on
les oublie toujours cela comme par
hasard du coup bon je comprends un peu
les complotistes qui affirment qu'on n'a
jamais posé le pied sur la lune parce
que passer de se faire mettre une raclée
intergalactique à envoyer des hommes
vers l'infini et au delà en moins de dix
ans y a de quoi surprendre plus d'un
même si on est les etats unis tout
puissant c'était plus facile pour eux de
louer un studio télé de saupoudrer un
peu de farine sur le sol la d'allumer
quelques spots à fond et de ralentir les
films pour faire comme si nos acteurs
danser sous une gravité réduite ce
serait vraiment le plus beau chef
d'oeuvre de stanley kubrick d'après
cette théorie le célèbre cinéaste
américain aurait aidé la nasa en
tournant l'alunissage parce qu'on
échange la nasa lui aurait fourni des
technologies pour qu'il tourne son film
de science-fiction 2001 l'odyssée de
l'espace et puis regardez moi ces
drapeaux qui flottent là alors qu'il ya
même pas d'air sur la lune j'en suis
convaincu les américains ont monté cette
duperie de toutes pièces faire croire
qu'ils avaient gagné la course à
l'espace bizarrement la théorie du
complot que je viens de vous présenter
n'est pas né en russie mais aux états
unis en 1974 sort un livre intitulé nous
ne sommes jamais allés sur la lune une
escroquerie à 30 milliards de dollars la
thèse de l'auteur est tout simplement
que la mission apollo 11 et les cinq
autres missions lunaires qui ont suivi
sont des supercheries l'auteur en
question bill kaysing a travaillé
quelques années dans le spatial il a pas
de formation scientifique ni en
ingénierie son job était de corriger les
fautes d'orthographe dans les
publications voilà donc qui a lancé
cette théorie du complot qui va toujours
bon train aujourd'hui et j'ai vraiment
envie d'y croire mais il ya quelques
petits éléments qui me chiffonne quand
même bien bas le drapeau justement on
vient de le citer le problème il n'y a
pas d'air sur la lune donc pas de vent
donc le drapeau orange est tout flagada
on n'aurait pas vu ce qu'ils avaient de
six ans a pu accrocher un vieux slip à
la place ça aurait fait le même effet et
ça c'est un peu ballot pour les états
unis qui voulaient bien qu'on voit que
c'était eux les plus forts imaginez vous
venez d'achever la peinture de votre vie
et vous voir et sur la signature ça la
fout mal mais les scientifiques sont des
gens très malin pour pallier ce léger
souci ils ont renforcé la toile du
drapeau avec des fils de fer et le
monter sur une barre de maintien
horizontale pour qu'ils tiennent droit
sans la moindre brise mais alors s'il
n'y a pas de vent pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
bougent un peu sur la vidéo tout
simplement parce que les astronautes
viennent de le planter et que le tissu
on est encore tour au musée est un
phénomène physique tout bête qu'on
appelle l'inertie et les traces de pâles
si la lune est véritablement constituée
de cheddar il n'y a pas de raison qu'on
n'y voit aussi bien ses empreintes de
boeck qui a que de la boue pour laisser
aussi bien les traces or il n'y a pas
d'eau sur la lune on nous ment en fait
la surface de notre satellite naturel
est recouverte d'une fine poussière qui
ressemble un peu à de la cendre
volcanique et qu'on appelle rigaud dit
quand on marche dessus c'est très facile
de la comprimer sous la forme de nos
empreintes de vote et en plus comme un
pas devant ces traces peuvent rester là
plus ou moins éternellement à moins
qu'une météorite viennent les dégommer
d'ailleurs je suis étonné que les
astronautes en ai pas profité pour faire
un ange de noël ou dessiner des bêtises
sur le sol vraiment je crois que nous
n'a pas les mêmes remettez allez une
petite dernière pour la route c'est pas
filmé en studio où sont les étoiles dans
le ciel me semble qu'on a quand même un
paquet dans l'espace on devrait au moins
avoir une ou deux dans full quoi et bien
la solution est tout simplement d'ordre
technique la lumière du soleil éclairait
si fort les premiers plans qu'il était
impossible de voir les étoiles à la
caméra vous pouvez essayer vous même
avec vos téléphones derrière sortait la
nuit éclairés quelqu'un au premier plan
avec une lampe et si vous le prenez en
photo telle qu'elle lui sera bien mais
on verra aucune étoile derrière si vous
voulez voir les étoiles il faudra faire
un petit réglage sur votre téléphone
vous verrez les étoiles mais votre
premier plan éclairer là il va être
complètement éclaté tout blanc c'est ce
qu'on appelle surexposé en photo ne peut
pas avoir le beurre et l'argent du
beurre dans notre cas les sujets à
éclairer et les étoiles dans les
appareils photo et les caméras ne
fonctionne juste pas comme ça donc voilà
pour ça cela dit il reste encore une
terrible zones d'ombré à cette théorie
du complot elle ne dit pas si tintin et
milou on veut véritablement foulée le
régolithe si vous avez des pistes
n'hésitez pas à m'en faire part je n'en
dors plus la nuit
[Musique]